THE FATE OF THE HERSHEV  REGION
IS UNCERTAIN AS RUSSIAN FORCES
MAY WITHDRAWAL SOON.
NICK ROBERTSON IS UNSEEN IN
UKRAINE WITH US.
NICK, ARE UKRAINIANS SEEING
SIGNS THAT RUSSIA IS RETREATING
FROM HERSON?
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
POLITICAL SPARRING BETWEEN BOTH
SIDES AND MILITARY MANEUVERS ON
THE GROUND.
THAT PERHAPS THERE IS GOING TO
BE A GREATER CONTEST.
A FIERCER CONTEST IN THE FUTURE
BUT WE ARE NOT THERE BUT ARE WE
HEARING FROM THE RUSSIAN BACKED
SIDE KHERSHON IN WE BELIEVE THEY
ARE IN CONVOYS WHERE WE CAN FROM
THE UKRAINIANS.
THE DEFENSE MINISTER SAID TODAY
HE BELIEVES IN ESSENCE BREAKING
DOWN HIS SARCASM.
THAT THE UKRAINIANS WILL HAVE TO
FIGHT KHERSHON FOR THE RUSSIANS
WERE NOT GOING TO GIVE IT BACK
DESPITE NOT HAVING MANY TROOPS
IN THE CITY DESPITE HARDENING
THE DEFENSE BUT THE UKRAINIANS
WILL HAVE TO FIGHT FOR IT THE
RUSSIANS WILL HAVE LOSSES.
AND HE ADDED AS WELL HE DID THE
RUSSIANS WOULD HAVE A TOUGH TIME
BECAUSE THEIR TRENCHES ARE IN
IRRIGATION DITCHES AROUND THE
SPORT CITY AND THERE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF RAIN.
AND IT IS TAKING DOWN TONIGHT
TRENCHES AROUND HERE WILL BE
FILLING UP.
AND IT WILL MAKE THE FIGHTING
HARDER FOR BOTH SIDES.
I THINK THE SIGNIFICANT MILITARY
MANEUVERS ARE AROUND THE KEY DAN
UPRIVER FROM KHERSHON THAT THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE SAID IF THEY GET
IT INSIDE OF THEIR ARTILLERY
DIRECTIONS WILL KNOW IT IS THE
ONLY ROUTE OF RETREAT THE GAME
IS THAT.
ESSENTIALLY AND THEY BELIEVE
GRADUALLY.
NOW THE RUSSIANS AND PRES. PUTIN
HAS REINFORCED THIS FORCING
CIVILIANS FROM VILLAGES ON THE
EAST BANK.
THE OPPOSITE SIDE FROM KHERSHON
AROUND THAT DAM AND JUST UPRIVER
FROM THE DAM WHICH MEANS THE
FIGHT MAKE IT STRONGER AND GET
CLOSER.
BUT AGAIN A LOT OF THIS IS
CONJECTURE THERE IS A LOT OF
POLITICAL SPARRING WITHOUT
MILITARY MANEUVERING.
>> NICK ROBERTSON IN FROM
T
KRAMATORSK,  I WANT TO GET MORE
FROM THE FORMER U.S. AMBASSADOR
TO UKRAINE BILL TAYLOR.
YOU HIT THE REPORT IT IS ALMOST
LIKE WILL WE TALK TO NICK ABOUT
EVERYDAY ON WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH KHERSHON BECAUSE IT IS
MURKY AS YOU SEE THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING NOW THAT
WE HAVE SEEN THE RARE WEIGH IN
FROM VLADIMIR PUTIN HIMSELF?
>> IT IS HARD TO SAY BUT
KHERSHON IS IMPORTANT TO BOTH
SIDES.
AND WHAT IS CLIFF THE RUSSIANS
ARE SENDING INEXPERIENCED TROOPS
PEOPLE THEY HAVE JUST CALLED UP
NOT MUCH TRAINING.
THEY WILL BE SITTING THERE ON
THE SIDE WHERE KHERSON IS THEY
ARE NOT WELL DISCIPLINED OR
TRAINED.
IF THEY PANIC LIKE WHAT HAPPENED
IN HARKEV THAT COULD HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON THE REST
OF THE RUSSIAN ARMY.
KHERSONIS IMPORTANT AND NEITHER
SIDE SHOWING THEIR HAND AND
SHOWING WHAT THEY WILL DO.
DO NOT PUT IT PAST THE
UKRAINIANS TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE
QUICK TO NOT LET THEM GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN? WHAT THEY DO NOT WANT TO
DESTROY DOWNTOWN KHERSON.
KHERSON IS BEAUTIFUL THEY DO NOT
WANT TO DESTROY IT BY ARTILLERY
BY HOUSE TO HOUSE FIGHTING.
THEY COULD BE LOOKING AT OTHER
WAYS TO MAKE THE RUSSIAN PASS.
>> THE U.S. AND ASKED 400
MILLION IN NEW SECURITY
ASSISTANCE AND A REVAMPED
COMMAND TO TRAIN THESE SOLDIERS.
IS THAT ENOUGH TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE THROUGH THIS? HERE FOR A
WHILE ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
CONSIDER WE HAVE THESE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS UPON US.
AND EVEN PARTIAL REPUBLICAN
CONTROL OF CONGRESS COULD STYMIE
EFFORTS TO GET MORE INTO
E
UKRAINE.
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT WHAT I
SEE IN TODAY'S CONGRESS.
>> YOU DO NOT BELIEVE REPUBLICAN
CONTROL. SUPPORT OF UKRAINE?
>> THAT IS RIGHT DO NOT BELIEVE
REPUBLICAN CONTROL OF THE HOUSE
WAS STOP REPORT FOR UKRAINE.
WHY? BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE FULL
RANGE OF CONGRESS IS LITTLE
CONCERN ON THE LEFT AND RIGHT.
BUT BASICALLY YOU HAVE A SOLID
BIPARTISAN MAJORITY.
AND IT TURNED OUT THERE ARE NOT
MANY CHANGES OF SEATS.
I DO NOT SEE A BIG CHANGE IN THE
NUMBERS I CERTAINLY DO NOT SEE
THE CONGRESS REDUCING
DRAMATICALLY SUPPORT.
I SEE IT CONTINUING AND IT WILL
TAKE REAL LEADERSHIP ON SEN.
MCCONNELL AND SEN. SCHUMER AND
NANCY PELOSI AND THE PRESIDENT
TO KEEP THE SUPPORT UP.
BECAUSE IT WILL BE HARD THIS
WINTER.
HERD HERE, HARD IN EUROPE BUT
HARDEST IN UKRAI